Xin chào mấy ông. Ờ hôm nay là
livestream đúng kiểu bất ngờ không báo
trước nhưng mà thì mình cũng bị lỡ không
học tận chẳng biết là từ hôm từ mấy rồi
đấy. ba kêu là hàng ngày học nhưng mà có
vẻ là tuần trước thì tôi lấy cớ là
ừ chuẩn bị cho tiệc cuối năm về tôi làm
cả đâu
đã livestream tận 8 ngày trước đấy nh
tuần live thì tôi lấy cớ có thể lấy cớ
là do đây chuẩn bị tiệc cuối năm mình
vừa là trong ban tổ chức vừa làm MC rồi
vừa dễ văn nghệ nữa
đấy Thì anti gravity mới thêm cái mới.
Tính là gần đây hôm hôm trước không biết
là mấy ông có dùng anti Gravity không?
Hôm trước antigravity có kiểu
không gọi như là không dùng được trong
vòng từ
2:00 chiều cho đến tầm chắc là đến tầm
tối đấy. thời gian đấy xong rồi tôi đang
vi code nên thành ra là kiểu bị gián
đoạn nên là phải kiểu à tải gấp win win
search quay lại win search thì mình nhớ
lại win search là kiểu nó cập nhật cái
này
hàng ngày cũng có dùng từ hàng ngày hơi
quá nhưng đại khái nó cập nhật liên tục
ví dụ giả sử ra được cái model mới model
ai mới nó sẽ tích hợp ngay vào trong cái
đấy nó rất là nhanh luôn ấy kiểu vừa mới
công bố là kiểu
thứ các thứ xong rồi tính năng cái chen
lắ nó rất nhiều con anti này tôi thấy
phải khởi ít khá là ít. Sanbox ồ sunbox
terminal cũng được nhưng mà tôi thấy
fixbox cần nhiều đây toàn cải thiện cái
gì đó fix hơi ít nhỉ.
chào các bạn chắc không phải bạn ngồi
cạnh mình tôi đâu.
Hôm nay chúng ta sẽ học Java. Đợi tí
thôi. Tìm lại cái bài hồi trước mình học
Java
từ hôm trước học thì bây giờ là phải tầm
một tuần nhỉ.
nhớ không? Đại khái thì tôi sẽ ngồi à ôn
lại kiểu ôn lại từ đầu quên mất
[khịt mũi] rồi buổi thứ năm đúng không
ạ?
Xong rồi. Còn buổi sáu buổi 10 này thì
chắc tí mình ngồi soạn tiếp dùng AI ngồi
tạo tiếp ra buổi buổi sáu đến buổi 12
hay là nói chung là những buổi sau đúng
không ạ? [khịt mũi]
Bài tập tức ra là mình cũng chưa làm bài
tập gì cả. Mình cũng ngồi xem lại các
thứ mình mới chỉ có dừng dừng lại kiểu
đọc kiểu code thôi. Đấy chưa làm bài tập
gì cả.
trong buổi này hôm nay nhá. À mấy ông có
gì mấy ông cứ chat nếu mà muốn tâm sự
cho chuyện gì đó nhá. Tôi vẫn sẽ kiểu
tôi vẫn để ý chat mà.
11.
Sao dù thời gian đầu là đúng mình vẫn
kiểu mapping 11 là so sánh PP có gì,
Java có gì đúng không ạ? [khịt mũi]
Nhưng mà thực ra là mình nên có cái túi
gì cốt lõi này đúng không?
Mental model này hôm trước tôi mới biết
hay phết
cùng mấy ông để ngồi đọc cái
mấy cái tôi chia sẻ ở trên server
Discord.
Server Discord. Server Discord tôi
thường hay chia sẻ gần đây chia sẻ càng
nhiều hơn bởi vì tham gia được nhiều
nhóm hơn ấy. Đặc biệt nhóm về ai thì đợi
tôi một tí
thì cho mấy ông có thể ngồi xem cùng
chúng ta ngồi đọc cùng. Ví dụ hôm trước
là anh a
anh Jam anh đấy có
rồi cả cái Ghub spec kit này hôm trước
anh Jam anh chia sẻ này thậm chí là
có bài chia sẻ của Bạn à hôm trước bạn à
đây series 2 này tôi cũng chưa đọc cơ tí
tôi nếu có thể tôi sẽ tí tôi sẽ ngồi đọc
cùng mấy ông nhá.
học một mình mình hơi chán thì bây giờ
có người ngồi đọc cùng ngồi học cùng
cũng hay đấy. Tận dụng cả AI còn cả nhân
hóa việc học của mình cùng lúc cùng mình
nó sẽ cảm thấy hay hơn. Tôi thấy thế.
này. Cái này thì mấy ông nhớ không ạ?
Cái này về kiểu dữ liệu nguyên thủy và
kiểu nó giống kiểu đối tượng class đúng
không ạ? Sẽ có thêm những cái gì? Có vẻ
tôi nhớ cái này. Ok. Tiếp theo string
pool này
tái sử dụng lại kiểu nó lưu một cái lư
vào pool và một cái lưu vào hip. Đúng
rồi. Nó tạo object mới trong hip. Cái
này là nó là grapper class vừa nãy đúng
không ạ?
Bị mất bas
đấy. Cáap mà đúng không nhỉ? Đang lên
plan học lại. [khịt mũi]
Thực ra là khi bị mất à
hồi trước tôi cũng từng nghĩ thế. Hồi
trước hồi mà tôi học tôi học nghề mà nên
là hồi trước tôi nghĩ là tôi luôn hỏng
về kiến thức bay kể hình ứng kiến kiến
thức nền xong rồi tôi nghĩ là kiểu tôi
phải nên ôn lại cái đấy nhưng mà về sau
tôi mới nhận ra là thực là không cần
thiết lắm khi mà mình có thể đi làm được
mục tiêu mình vẫn là để đi làm mà đúng
không
đương nhiên là không nói là kiến thức nó
không quan trọng nhá nói là
lúc đấy ông mới thực sự là biết được là
mình cần học những cái gì đấy. Còn nếu
bây giờ toàn bộ kiến thức bây giờ ông
vẫn đủ ấy thì có thể có thể thôi nhá là
ông vẫn đủ dùng rồi. Nhưng mà nó vẫn sẽ
có một cái nhược điểm nữa đó là hôm
trước nghe nói khái niệm đó là mình
không biết là mình không biết.
Ừ đấy gọi điểm mù ấy mấy ông biết cái
cái nhiệm đấy không? Đó là kiểu bình
thường là ông biết là ông biết những cái
gì, ông biết là ông không biết những cái
gì.
Đấy. Và ông không biết là ông không biết
cái gì. Ví dụ giả sử không biết được là
à là là
vân vân. Đấy, phải khi có người khai
sáng ra mình thì mình mới biết chứ mình
chỉ biết được là mình không biết Java
thôi chứ mình không hề biết được là Java
nó có thể như thế nào. Đấy, thì ví dụ là
ông làm ông đang kêu ông thiếu bị thiếu
kiến thức gì đó,
đúng là sẽ có một ngày nào đó kiến thức
đấy nó quan trọng thì
nó có thể sẽ giới hạn khả năng của mình
và giới hạn cả cơ hội. Ví dụ giả sử cơ
hội để mà mình thăng tiến hơn mình lên
làm à kiểu quản lý rủ ro quản lý không
phải dùng quản lý do hơi quá nhỉ kiểu
phân tích thiết kế hệ thống này xong rồi
hoặc là tối ưu này vân vân những cái a
chức vụ quan trọng hơn những cái row
những cái vai trò kiểu xịn hơn thì lúc
đấy phải đòi hỏi cái kiến thức nền phải
vững hơn vì lúc đấy mình không chỉ dừng
ở việc bit code nữa thì đến lúc đấy là
ông sẽ biết được là à còn thiếu rất
nhiều và ông cần phải được khai sáng
nhiều. Còn đến thời điểm hiện tại nói
chung là nó phải ngưỡng như nào đã. Ví
dụ nhá ông mới a đi làm 2 năm chẳng hạn
thực ra ông vẫn chỉ cần dừng ở việc bit
code thôi. Ông không cần biết tối ưu vì
chẳng ai cho ông động vào cả. Ông làm gì
có kinh nghiệm đúng không? Đấy không
phải đi làm đủ lâu để mà
cái quan trọng đó là tôi có biết đặc
biệt trong ngành ngành này tôi biết nhá
ngành khác thì tôi không rõ lắm nhưng
tôi biết được là có rất nhiều anh em
tính ngành này bằng năm kinh nghiệm
nhưng thực ra nó đôi khi nó không đúng
lắm vì có rất nhiều anh em kiểu 3 4 năm
liền vẫn chỉ làm những cái tính năng
kiểu thêm xử xóa thôi thì kiến thức của
họ sẽ chỉ dừng ở mức độ đấy thì nó vẫn
vẫn gọi là gì ạ không thể lấy Đấy má là
cả s được midle có khi còn chưa biết thế
nào nhá. Nghĩa họ vẫn chỉ dừng ở việc
biết code thôi. Đấy thì họ không biết
tối ưu. Họ không không quan tâm đến tối
ưu luôn. Ví dụ giả sử Java này là liên
quan đến bộ nhớ này, liên quan đến a
[khịt mũi]
xử lý đá luồng, xử lý gì đó phức tạp và
và có thể phân tích ra. Cái quan trọng
ấy ông cứ hình dung là cái quan trọng ấy
đó là khi mà sếp ông hỏi là
em có ý tưởng gì cho cái tính năng này.
Đấy ông chỉ để xuất ra được đúng một ý
tưởng, đúng một giải pháp thôi là chứng
tỏ là ông chưa, chưa có kiến thức hoặc
chưa được nghĩ đủ nhiều cho những cái
đấy.
Đấy ông ông hình dung không? Ví dụ là
kiểu hồi trước là tôi đề xuất được hai,
ít nhất là hai cho đến ba giải pháp và
mỗi cái đều có ưu nhược. Đấy, tôi không
nói là tôi đã lên đến cái tầm rất là xịn
nhá nhưng mà ý tôi hướng đến là thế. Và
sếp cũng sẽ thích nghe kiểu thế. Ông
hình dung không? Sếp sẽ thích nghe được
kìa
là sếp được quyền lựa chọn chứ đếu phải
kiểu tao chỉ em chỉ biết làm mỗi một cái
thôi.
Xong rồi anh anh hỏi thế thì em chỉ biết
làm mỗi cái này em đề xuất mỗi cái này.
Đấy xong rồi anh đề xuất cái khác chịu
em không làm được. Không phải thế đúng
không ạ? Mình
mình phải cho sếp nhiều lựa chọn để sếp
quyết định và mình nói được ưu và nhược
để sếp đỡ phải suy nghĩ càng tốt. Sếp sẽ
chỉ cần thấy là ok. Em thấy à ví dụ hồi
đấy nhá tôi từng đề xuất hai giải pháp
một cái là sử dụng luôn cái thư viện ở
bên thứ ba. Đấy nó sẽ có nguy hiểm là
mình phải phụ thuộc bên đấy hay vân vân
gì đó. Còn giải pháp thứ hai mình đập đi
làm lại có thể tốn thời gian hơn nhưng
mà mình sẽ làm kiểm soát được đúng
không? Mình quản lý được và mình hiểu
được luồng thậm chí về xong mình custom
được vân vân vân vân. Đấy thì đây lên
hai phương án để mà sếp kiểu duyệt để
sếp cảm thấy là nếu mình có thời gian
thì mình sẽ làm phương án nào đúng
không?
Nếu thường là các sếp nếu mà không phải
anh CTO nhá mà anh CO kiểu CEO ấy kiểu
nói chung là những ông không phải chuyên
về công nghệ ông sẽ thường liên quan đến
tối ưu chi phí thì ông sẽ thường là chọn
những cái giải pháp nào mà tối ưu chi
phí nhất. Đôi khi là tối ưu chi phí đây
không nhất thiết phải tiền mà thực ra là
liên quan thời gian. Thối ưu chi phí
thời gian thời gian cũng là tiền mà đúng
không? Đấy nhưng mà CTO thì họ sẽ thiên
một tí về công nghệ nghĩa họ phải hiểu
được cái bài toán gọi là
khái niệm gần đây tôi có biết nó từ ch à
chắc bạn biết thế này. Check off là bài
toán đánh đổi đấy. Mình sẽ đánh đổi dạng
như nào đúng không ạ? Đấy thì nhiều
người đánh đổi chấp nhận đánh đổi chấp
nhận đánh đổi thời gian chấp nhận đánh
đổi tiền bạc để mình
quản lý kiểm soát được nó. Và công ty
hơi tôi hồi trước làm thế thật đó là bởi
vì về sau còn định làm hẳn cái để mà làm
cái dịch vụ để cho bên khác thuê luôn.
Mình bên mình dùng bên mình không tốn
tiền quá nhiều chi phí cho bên thứ ba
đúng không? Và thậm chí mình còn lại mở
dịch vụ để cho người khác dùng. Đấy,
kiểu thế.
một thôi nhưng mà mình trả lời hơi dài
bởi vì kiểu mình muốn nó kiểu nó phải
rộng ra nó phải rõ ràng hơn ấy. Còn nếu
mà chỉ trả lời ngắn gọn thì à thực ra
đấy còn không phải là câu hỏi cơ nhở,
chỉ là câu kể thôi. Nhưng mà nếu mà mình
trả lời ngắn gọn quá thì nó
kiểu dạng
nó không nói rõ được cái cái con người
hay suy nghĩ của mình đã nghĩ đúng không
ạ?
Làm sao? Đôi khi chia sẻ tôi nghĩ là mấy
ông có thể thấy thích à ít nhất là
thoáng nghe tôi thì sẽ thích nghe tôi
bởi vì à dễ ngủ à không biết được từ
nghe tôi để mà à không để ngồi làm việc
nó vừa ngồi code nó vừa ngồi nghe tôi à
không nhưng cái đoạn đấy là đoạn tâm sự
chứ không phải đoạn này không phải một
cái đoạn ngồi chia sẻ kiến thức nhưng mà
tôi nghĩ là tôi chia sẻ kiến thức cho
mấy ông cũng có lúc hay có rất nhiều lúc
có mấy ông
nói lại tôi nói lại dùng tới nói lại nó
không đúng lắm đại khái là kiểu kiểu
ngồi sửa cho tôi ấ tôi thấy là sửa chứ
không phải ném đá đâu. Tôi thấy ít ra
chưa trên kênh tôi chưa có ai ném đá
chắc mình cũng chưa đổi nổi tiếng nhưế
thế chưa có đi fan đấyan
đấy thì
trên này thực không phải fan cơ trên này
mấy ông chẳng phải fan của tôi chưa phải
thần tượng hay hâm mộội gì cả người
thường với nhau cả chẳng qua là mình
kiểu thấy vui vui vui. Đầu tiên là chắc
là tôi thấy là mấy ông biết tôi qua vui
vui vui kiểu
ờ kiểu dạng tự nhiên thấy có một ông à
đăng trên J2 thì thấy là hay kêu là miễn
phí rồi. Thôi vào xem có cái gì đấy.
nghe. Ồ, kiểu mấy ông bật lên tôi thực
ra là tôi sợ mấy ông phân tâm thôi chứ
bình thường là tôi ngồi code thì tôi
không ngồi nghe ai nói cả mà tôi sẽ
thường khi mà tôi ngồi code thì tôi sẽ à
gần đây không vai vai gần đây vai code
nhiều hơn không ngồi code mấy nữa nhưng
mà cũng mở nhạc nó nhẹ nhẹ để mình suy
nghĩ
thứ cho nó không anh Ở bạn có thể xem a
video hôm video ngay video trước của
mình mình có nhắc về bộ set kit rồi các
thứ thứ cũng nhiều phết dùng antigravity
kit xong rồi kiểu thêm ru thêm skin.
Nhưng mà hôm trước là tôi dùng chính con
AI này tôi ngồi đọc cả cho nó đọc mấy
cái bộ nghĩa là cái kit đấy bản chất là
gồm à
skin này, workflow này với ru này còn gì
nhá.
Tạm thời tôi nhớ thế.
Ngồi ngồi đọc mấy cái đấy xong rồi đọc
project của tôi xong rồi sửa lại cái
đống đấy để cho nó hợp lý và tôi đẩy
lên. Và mấy ông này thực ra là cũng thể
trách mấy ông ấy được. Tức là mấy ông ấy
tạo ra một cái thư mục ví dụ thằng này
thì nó sẽ tạo ra thư mục là chấm agent
đúng không? Thằng khác thì tạo thư mục
ví dụ core là chấm cusor, thằng winsert
là chấm winsert. Thằng khác nữa thì tôi
chưa dùng nhưng đại khái mỗi thằng tạo
ra một cái thư mục ru à thư mục riêng
của nó. Xong rồi nó có chấm thư mục
thường là nó vẫn sẽ có những thư mục
rule, skin, rflow nan nào giống nhau. Có
thằng khác mỗi tên thư mục thôi nhưng mà
đều là file ma down mà đúng không? Thế
tôi ức chế quá hôm trước tôi làm quà tôi
nhờ AI ngồi custom lại đúng không? Tôi
tạo hẳn một thư mục là chấm.
Xong rồi tôi tạo sim link. Mấy ông cho
biết khái niệm này. Sim link
này đúng không? Thì hiện tại antiravity
nó sẽ có thư mục chấm agent xong rồi
gạch chéo ru. Đúng chưa? Đấy thằng CO nó
cũng sẽ kiểu như thế nhưng chẳng qua nó
là chậm coo ở đây đúng không? Đấy.
Đấy. Tôi tôi tạo một thư mục là đấy
ch ru như này. Đấy. So những cái thằng
này nó là sim link tức là nó sẽ kiểu bản
chất là nó nối à nó kiểu gọi là trỏ đến
cái thư mục góc kia kìa. Bởi vì trong
công ty của tôi là có
người dùng CO, có người dùng Cloue, tôi
thì dùng à Winser à dùng ừ tôi hồi trước
tôi cũng dùng Winser còn bây giờ dùng
antigravity. Đấy thì tôi xét luôn bộ
rule ở trong này xong tôi kết nối hết
mấy thằng tròn như đây. Xong đấy.
Tôi còn đang định làm cái plugin cơ. Hôm
trước có một ông chia sẻ ở trong nhóm
nhóm antigravity à Việt Nam đấy. Xong
người chia sẻ cái extension. Tôi nghĩ là
tôi sẽ ngồi vai code hẳn một cái
extension rồi tôi đẩy lên xong rồi à làm
mấy cái kiểu đồng bộ với cái vụ kiểu như
này. Tại vì thằng Antigravity này nó có
cái tạo ra cái plan đúng không? Hôm
trước mấy ông thấy á nó tạo ra mấy cái
plan nó cái luồng suy nghĩ các thứ thứ
này này. Đây không biết được là trong
cộng này còn không.
Đây đây đây. À không
tôi bảo nó ghi thẳng vào rồi.
Đại khá là đôi khi thằng này có luồng
suy nghĩ nó sẽ tạo ra một cái file M
down
nêu lại nó đang nghĩ gì nhưng nó lại lưu
ở trong cái thư mục chấm Gemini ở ngoài
user ấy. Đấy tôi muốn và nó sẽ bị nhược
điểm là sao? Ông đổi máy tính. Ví dụ tôi
dùng cả máy tính công ty, dùng máy tính
cá nhân thì khi tôi đổi máy tính là coi
như là tôi sẽ không có cái file đấy vì
file đấy đang nằm trong thư mục ngoài.
Ông hình dung giống như là trong thư mục
của system ổ C ấy. Đấy thì rõ ràng là có
một cái tiện ích đồng bộ. Hôm trước là
có anh chia sẻ cái tiện ích đấy đấy
nhưng mà tôi dùng tôi bị lỗi. Tôi nghĩ
là tôi sẽ tự việt hẳn tiện ích diệc lấy
ý tưởng anh đấy và làm thêm cái quả đồng
bộ mấy cái ru rủng này này n vân vân rất
nhiều cái nữa. Chắc là kiểu gì sẽ có
người viết rồi. Nhưng mà bây giờ mình có
hay tự code thôi.
Ngày xưa sinh viên trường ông có đào tạo
Java không mà khổ như vậy?
Tôi học BTIS full Java, giờ chỉ học
sping là ổn rồi, không phải học lại Java
con nữa. Tôi cũng xuất thân từ Laria.
Trường tôi có dạy Java nhưng mà trường
tôi là trường nghề. Trường tôi dạy PP
trước xong rồi làm dự án bằng project dự
án dự án một, dự án hai bằng PP. Đấy,
xong rồi. Hồi đấy còn không có Larel để
à La Larel hồi đấy quá cũ à không phải
quá mới kiểu Lel hồi đấy là Laro 5 hay
không nhớ L mấy PP ở đây PP 5.6 sáu gì
vậy mà đại khái thì h đấy lại không dùng
chỉ dạy về PP MVC và một tí thôi xong
rồi làm dự án xong rồi
52 nhá xong rồi đã đi làm đi thực tập
rồi đấy 53 thì những bạn nào mà không
theo được không kiểu không đi thực tập
được rồi
thì mới ở lại trường để học th tiếp thì
sẽ học Java và học Android đấy đương
nhiên là tôi cũng có học Java cả Java
Java 1, Java 2 phải đấy học code để thi
thôi chứ không bởi vì mình đi được tầm
mình đi làm rồi mình đang làm PP các thứ
hồi đấy còn ngon lành thì rõ ràng là tự
nhiên chuyển qua học Java để làm dự án
Java làm gì đúng không?
mà giờ nhìn ông học Java co khổ quá
không khổ gì đâu. Tôi học cũng chỉ để
kiểu
tôi không tôi không nghĩ là khổ. Đầu
tiên là mình phải tư tưởng thế đã mình
không cảm thấy mệt, mình không cảm thấy
khổ. Mình cảm thấy nó bình thường đấy.
Thứ hai là học nhanh mà ông th xem mấy
video trước của tôi có thể hơn tiếng như
thự ra tôi ngồi nói chuyện như này nhiều
đấy. Họ cũng không nhiều lắm đâu. Đương
nhiên là nghe 100 ngày cũng nhiều. Xong
rồi mình mỗi buổi mỗi buổi lẻ tẻ lẻ tẻ
nó bị kiểu tốn thời gian đúng. Nhưng mà
tôi thứ nhất là nó đang chưa quan trọng
là mình cần ngay. Thế nên là tôi sẽ cảm
thấy mình thưa thưa mình cứ học dần học
dần để mình biết.
Bởi vì cái đầu tiên ấy, cái đầu tiên tôi
thấy cốt lõi nhất ấy đó là mình làm cho
tư tưởng của mình đó là ham học là kiểu
mình phải học một cái gì đó hàng ngày.
Tránh cái việc là mình bị thụ động quá
mỗi ngày qua ngày mà thực ra mình không
có thêm kiến thức gì mới. Đấy mới là cái
mà tôi cảm thấy là về sau nó sẽ gây khổ
mình đúng không? Đấy, còn mình học hàng
ngày và nó có áp dụng thật mà nó tốt
chẳng sao. Có thể là chưa áp dụng được
ngay bởi vì mình chưa dùng Java. Nhưng
mà thứ nhất là hôm trước tôi ngồi đọc
cái kia tôi cảm thấy hay này về mấy vụ
bộ nhớ này PP nó không để ý lắm vụ này.
ai cũng ai ở trên công ty tôi cũng thấy
bỡ ngỡ khi mà tôi cảm thấy là tôi giành
về mấy cái vụ AI này hơn mọi người th là
tôi không dành lắm đâu. chẳng qua là
tôi xin cảm ơn Facebook vì gần đây thay
đổi thật toán toàn cho tôi đề xuất những
cái bài mà tôi không hề theo dõi kiểu
những cái người lạ hoàn toàn ấy nhưng mà
đều nhắc đến AI này đều nhắc đến gì đó
thì mình dù mình cóo hay không kiểu
tôi dạo này dùng từ nhiều nhưng tôi
không biết nói câu này gì dù mình có
[khịt mũi] gì sợ bị à
sợ bị gọi là lỗi thời à chạy đua hay
không vân vân thì mình vẫn
tôi tôi không sợ hẳn là mình bị lạc hậu
đến thế nhưng mà chỉ kiểu thấy đầu tiên
là thấy trên trang chủ mình hay mình đọc
và mình ngẫm đấy xong mình tự nhiên mình
biết thôi xong mình cũng tìm hiểu thêm
là mình cũng áp dụng cho công việc của
mình hồi trước thì chắc là ông biết tôi
từ thời đầu rồi tôi còn dùng
chỉ PP Stone kiểu
VS code hay nào không quan tâm PP Stone
chân đấy đây chuyển qua mà khi một khi
mà mình mở cái đầu mình ra sẵn sàng chủ
qu chuyển qua rồi ấy mấy cái này không
tôi không ngại thay đổi ví dụ hôm trước
dùng antiity bất ôi chuyển lại Winsert
Winsert thầy tốn tiền quá chuyển qua
cusa đấy tôi chưa qua CL La code thôi vì
nó vẫn thiên hướng không phải là code mà
nó là ông ra lệnh nó nhiều nó là cái
giao diện của terminal ra lệnh thôi.
Ừ thực ra là ý ông ấy khổ đây ám chỉ
chắc là ám chỉ là hôm trước thì ông ấy
may mà ông ấy đã được học trước các thứ
thứ gọi là bây giờ áp dụng ổn. Còn mình
thì anh em mình là PP sắp chết rồi mà PP
thì mình bị lỗi thời rồi đấy. Mình phải
chuyển qua nhanh không thì hẹo. Đấy cũng
có cái bất cập mà. Ơ bây giờ giả sử PP
còn là vua chắc là tôi không.
Ừ, chắc tôi vẫn sẽ học Java đấy. Nhưng
mà để mà củng cố kiến thức PP kiểu OOP
thôi. OP và nhưng mà tôi bảo rồi, Java
này vẫn sẽ có những cái hay nó là
hôm trước sếp tôi đã từng hỏi cái câu
đấy rồi bá. Nếu mà anh hỏi em ở không
phỏng vấn, nếu anh là người phỏng vấn
em, có khi em không đu phá công ty mua
tội may là xếp tôi vào sau tối. Anh đấy
là anh leader hồi đầu công ty tôi bé thì
không có một leader thật sự mà chỉ có
anh CTO thôi. Vì sao công ty to ra thì
như là tuyển thêm một anh PM, một anh
leader về đúng không? Đấy thì ý tôi là
cái anh đấy anh đấy hỏi tôi bảo là đây
em thử trả lời câu ấy ừ mấy ông ở đây có
để thử hỏi mấy ông nhá không không chơi
cha mạng nhá đấy đó là interface khác gì
phải up check cl đấy anh ấy bảo hỏi câu
đấy
tôi đương nhiên tôi đưa ra những cái ví
dụ có rồi xong rồi anh em bảo không thế
em chưa hiểu rõ về cái cốt lõi về bản
chất các thứ các thứ
luôn PP không dùng
thậm chí là không dùng cả hai vẫn code
được đúng không ạ? Đương nhiên mình
không thể chơi cùn là kiểu dạng thích
cái em không dùng á MVC em không dùng PP
à không dùng Oop em dùng thuần code được
đúng không? Nhưng mà đang nói là đúng
nghĩa là nếu mà làm PP nhiều ông sẽ biết
rất ít dự án dùng interface. Tôi đấy là
góc nhìn tôi tôi biết nhá. Rất ít dự án
PP dùng interface
ABCK class thì tôi từng thấy rồi nhưng
mà thường theo mang tiếng là class xong
rồi kiểu extend nhau xong rồi kiểu kiểu
kế thừa nhau mà hóa dùng chết nhiều đúng
không? Đấy dùng chết là rất là nhiều.
Tôi thấy lạm dụng chết luôn đấy. Hồi
trước tôi cũng từng lạm dụng quả object
class xong rồi cứ kế thừa kế thừa xong
rồi về sau nó bị ấ à kiểu mình cố gom
mấy cái gì chung chung mình cho cái
class to class cha xong rồi các thứ thứ
thế rồi về sau ôi cốt rồi vãi xấu vãi.
lúc đấy mới thì bây giờ mới bắt đầu nhận
ra dần về interface nó có vẻ hay hơn.
cái đấy và phân biệt được rõ luôn. Mấy
ông có thể câu thấy câu đấy dễ nếu mấy
ông đã từng học Java. Còn tôi cứ cho là
tôi mất gốc Java nên là thì khó
hả? Học dốt á.
Java Java 2 của anh hình như là được 9
hay được 10 đấy.
Ô nhờ tí tôi sẽ tìm lại cái bảng điểm
à [hắng giọng] của tôi. Sếp tôi khoe là
bảng điểm đại học của sếp rất sáng.
Bảng điểm đại học của tôi cũng sáng. Tôi
nhớ tôi được 10 phẩy chính trị với 9
phẩy à đốc 9 phẩ luật với 10 phẩ chính
trị thì phải
thì chạy sang mấy cái đấy nhưng ý tôi là
mấy cái kiểu nó liên quan đến Hàn Lâm à
không hàn lâm kiểu triết lý hay vân vân
có gì đấy mình cũng thấm được mà mình
cứ gọi là mình à mấy cái đấy
với mình cũng không tính là khô khan nó
vẫn hiểu được
video mai xem lại chúc anh học tốt ạ em
cũng đi học đây được em ơi chúng ta cùng
học hôm nay tôi còn nghỉ cuộc chơi đị để
ngồi học cơ mà từ chối cuộc chơi để học
kiểu
anh em cũng c thấy bột cưới đúng
tôi thấy tôi nhớ được đống này rồi ạ tôi
thấy tương đối nhớ cùng lắm mà string
builder string buffer này hôm trước ngày
chưa thể xem ạ
bất biến này
cái nào bất biến string m khai báo như
này bất biến ok string mới không sửa
string cũ
tạo giác
sẽ chèn thêm kiểu gọi hàm để builder mà
đúng không? Nó giống như kiểu SQL
builder ừ để mà kiểu chèn thêm các thứ
thứ. Còn string buffer là vừa kết hợp
builder cộng với trve. À đúng rồi. Hôm
trước nhắc về vụ trap save này tức là
khi mà xử lý bất đồng bộ thì nó tránh bị
lỗi kiểu khi mà giá trị nó thay đổi đúng
không? [khịt mũi]
Nhưng mà chậm hơn string builder đúng
không? Còn đây string này là string
thuần nhỉ? Khai báo như này cộng thêm.
Nhưng mà cái này có lưu vào ghi đè bộ
nhớ không? ghi đè vào cái a địa chỉ bộ
nhớ đấy không nhỉ? Chắc là có chứ đúng
không? Khách báo như này ghi đè vào địa
chỉ bộ nhớ.
Nếu thế sao lại tốn chuỗi chuỗi nhiều à
sao tốn bộ nhớ và chậm nhỉ
nghĩa là bị lặp à kiểu một cái là hello
một cái hello world ở hai chỗ khác nhau
à
đúng không? Ừ. Đấy kêu tặng một cái mới
thế
đúng là học Java sầu mới biết cái này
chứ với PP chắc là tôi nghĩ hai kiểu nó
lưu vào cùng chỗ đấy đúng không?
Ok.
Thế mà hôm trước mình không thắc mắc
này. Đấy n đôi khi phải ôn lại để mà
kiểu
thắc mắc thêm.
code để mà còn in ra mấy cái gì đó này
mình còn chưa làm vụ chạy code á.
Để hôm sau tôi sẽ ngồi hôm sau không
biết hôm sau hôm nào nhưng hôm sau
còn cả hit và stack này nữa. Stack ngon
set này. Lưu chữ biến cục bộ tham chiếu
method core frame. Thực ra hôm trước
không để cái quả này. Hôm trước tôi nhớ
là hôm trước anh em đã tôi đã cùng anh
em để ngồi soạn cái quả này. Đợi tôi một
tí. Tôi nhớ hôm nấy là tôi
dùng cái napkin à napkin AI để ngồi soạn
và cũng ngồi khoe với cái napkin này.
trong Java stack và hip. Tài liệu này
trinh bày chi tiết về cấu trúc bộ nhớ
tập trung vào hai phần chính stack và
hip. Đấy và là trong Java bộ nhớ chia
nhiều phần hai phần quan trọng nhất là
stack qu hi được sử dụng để lưu chữ biến
cục bộ tham số phương thức và địa chỉ
trả về của phương thức.
Phương thức ở đây method đúng không? Nó
hoạt động theo nguyên tắc lain first
out. Đúng rồi. Stack đúng rồi.
và m
việc quản lý bộ nhớ hip được thực hiện
bởi
Git collector
chức năng của cái tôi nhớ không nhờ lầm
là cái Rabit.
collector này nó còn là
còn được nhắc đến ở trong PP không nói
nhá trong ngữ lập trình không nói nhá
tôi nhớ là còn [khịt mũi] hình như hình
như là được nhắc đến vào trong SQL phải
có đúng không nhỉ
hay là thằng khác nhỉ nhóm m máng là thế
thì thử hỏi lại cái này
sau lưu chữ biến cục bộ
chữ tham số phương thức
tham số của method đúng không gọi là
parameter rồiấy đúng không
nhớ khi một phương thức được gọi tham số
được truyền chữ stack ok chữ địa chỉ trả
về khi một phương thức kết thúc chương
trình cần biết địa chỉ để quay lại
phương thức được gọi
tiếng Việt nó mấy ông thấy là nó cũng
gọi nhá. Không được dễ nhìn thấy lắm
đúng không?
rồi nhưng mà tiếng Việt trên này không
dễ nhìn lắm nhỉ.
vãi chưởng. Đ gọi một stack fame được
tạo trên stack. Ui, cái này chịu cái này
phải làm mới biết được rồi.
Mình
cái tiện ích này của tôi đang tự đập bật
ạ. Tiếp nhá. Đợi tôi tắt cái này đi.
Đây bấm R AI này là xong. Đấy ra lệnh nó
giống viết nó một prom mà nó sẽ tự viết
cho mình cái tài liệu như này. Đấy xong
rồi mình bôi toàn bộ như này x ấn nút
này này là nó sẽ tạo cho mình cái một
cái sơ đồ ở dưới như này. Xịn không? Cái
này ch hồi trước tôi dùng chuyên để viết
tài liệu dạy học với tạo cái ảnh ở dưới
thì mình nhúng vào PowerPoint đúng
không? PowerPoint mình ít chữ thôi, chỉ
có ảnh thôi. Đấy,
có tài liệu
đúng không? Vừa làm tài liệu Doc, vừa
làm tài liệu PowerPoint
hả?
Đấy
ví dụ à
đợi tôi dicate này tránh lỗi
đấy. Ví dụ là
à
generic
trong Java. Thế này xong đây tự viết hết
kể cả tiếng Việt rất đỉnh.
Tôi dùng cái này từ
kiểu bây giờ là chắc là
cũng gần 2 năm rồi phải gần 2 năm.
Đó xong. Ok chưa?
Đấy xong rồi. Ấn ông đương nhiên ông bơi
từng đoạn này ông thể tạo được nhá.
Nhưng mà bôi tất cả này ấn tạo này. Và
nó miễn phí đúng không? Đấy miễn phí
nhá. Không mất đồngo cả. Đương nhiên là
khi mà đấy nó tạo ra cho ông rất nhiều
cái kiểu như nàyi để mà ông có thể
đây sửa được nó nhá. ở đây sửa được này.
Hay đủ các thứ thứ này.
mình export ra mình thể chọn này. Tôi
thường ha chọn độ phân giải cao này
không có background để mà mình khi mà
mình copy ấ
khi copy ra
đây copy ra ảnh nó sẽ rất là nét đấy.
Kiểu thế tốt
đấy. Không background nhá. Không có có c
thì để mình copy ra chỗ khác mà thì nền
nó sẽ là nền BNG mà nó sẽ nền trong
suốt.
Ngon mà miễn phí. Đương nhiên là hồi
trước là nó không có logo cơ. Gần đây nó
cho thêm logo mất tiền chỉ tắt đi cái
logo là quá quá rẻ nhở.
napkin AI nhá. Nakin. Đấy con này đang
miễn phí đấy. Không biết được mấy ông
đăng ký tài khoản bây giờ thì nó như
nào. Tôi thì đăng nhập bằng tài khoản
Google lâu rồi. Không biết là bởi vì tôi
còn từng chat với bên đấy cơ để nói
chuyện kiểu thoải mái lắm. Hồi trước
từng chat mấy lần thì không biết được
bên này có tạo điều kiện cho nick tôi
hay không. Không biết được.
Mấy ông có thể dùng thử mất tiền thì
thôi. Còn nếu mà miễn phí thì rõ ràng là
mình
tiện mình dùng đúng không?
Vậy thì đang học bên này à kích thước cố
định này được xác định khi chương trình
khởi động. Nhớ cố gắng tạo à đây stack
flow. Ok.
Đ hiểu này.
Ồ. Tại sao không ai nói mình đoạn này?
Không không học m cái này.
JVM. Jv
học là stack với các thứ h stack thôi.
Ừ. Stack với hip.
>> Mấy cái đấy ấ dụ nó chỉ kiểu lý thuyết
thôi. Còn khi nào mà nó đi làm
>> đúng anh anh nghĩ là kiểu nó có thể là
có thể là nhiều người làm rồi cũng không
nhưng mà
>> đế án đi làm sao còn bình thường mà nếu
mà không thì cũng chỉ đọc lý thuyết
thôi.
>> Có bây giờ có ai có thể báo đưa ví dụ
hiệu cũng chỉ học thuộc thế. Ừ anh nghĩ
là hồi này anh cũng học trên trường rồi
nhưng anh quên xử hết rồi có nhiều đâu.
>> Còn stack thì đương nhiên biết về khái
niệm l in first out phải có stack với
kill khác nhau như nào?
đúng bạn đấy cũng a
bạn ấy cũng làm à à công nghệ thông tin
nhưng bạn ấy làm Java nên tôi bảo bạn
ngồi học cùng thì bạn ấy còn chỉ được à
bạn
ấy làm mà
thực ra là tôi để công khai trên
Facebook chẳng qua mấy không để ý tôi ấ
à có khi mấy cũng không biết Facebook
tôi nhỉ quên mất
nhớ.
Chắc là người ta khi phỏng vấn tôi không
hỏi mấy câu đấy đâu. Bây bây giờ bây giờ
tôi sang kia tôi không phải phỏng vấn
theo dạng là kiểu đấy. Thực ra đấy nhược
điểm đấy. Không biết mấy ông đã bị dính
cái đấy chưa? Bây giờ mình kêu là mình
là senior. Cứ giả sử thế đi. Có cái mio
đi. Sino pp
xong rồi sang khác là đi phỏng vấn fer
Java à cũng không được đúng không? Mình
phỏng vấn thấp nhất. Thấp nhất nhá. Tôi
nghĩ phải middle đấy. Thấp nhất
midle thì người ta chắc là sẽ không hỏi
mấy câu này đâu. JVM là cái gì
[tiếng cười]
đúng không?
là nhược điểm của anh em trong a ngành
này hiện tại. Đấy gần đây là tôi có biết
đấy. Ví dụ xếp tôi bây giờ lead này. Đấy
bây giờ sang bên công ty khác một là làm
lead, hai là phải làm to hơn cao hơn là
sang công ty khác đi làm nhân viên thì
thực ra là người ta kiểu thắc mắc ý kiến
ấy. Lương cũ của mày như nào mà bây giờ
mày có thể chấp nhận lương có thể trả
bằng 1/3 đến thế chẳng hạn. Thế
đấy người ta sẽ thắc mắc rất nhiều cho
dù rõ ràng mình thì thực ra mình chỉ cần
có việc thôi đúng không? Mình cũng đuối
đuối rồi đi. Đấy, mình cũng không thể
nào nhanh nhạy được bằng cái mới. Đấy,
thì cố góp vốn rồi đi mở một cái gì đó,
thậm chí mở công ty, mở setup. Đấy, mở
set up thì khi mà sát nhăn nhàn thực ra
tỉ lệ thành công nó cũng không phải cao
nữa.
Ví dụ là cái này cũng nằm trong stack
đúng không? Cái biến cục bộ nằm trong
stack này. Cái biến này trả về từ method
cũng nằm trong stack đấy. Tôi nhớ không?
Ừ.
Ok. Cái này cũng nằm trong stack này
đúng không?
Nhưng mà tôi nhớ là hôm trước có cái này
nếu mà khai báo nó là
[khịt mũi] wrapper class đúng không? Thì
nó nằm trong hip à?
Đúng rồi. Nó nằm trong hip đúng không?
[khịt mũi]
được tạo trên stack trừ các biến xy res
khi phương thức add kết thúc stack bị
khó xóa khỏi stack được. Nó giống như PP
này nghĩa là kiểu kết thúc cái method
thì sẽ xóa nó khỏi bộ nhớ cho nhẹ. Đấy.
Ừ. Thì bên Java làm quản lý bộ nhớ tốt
phết nhở.
>> Cuối cùng khi phương thức main kết thúc
cũng m stack frame đấy chính là main này
đúng không? Cũng xóa. Ừ toàn bộ biến cục
bộ xóa. Ok hợp lý đấy. Bởi vì bản thất
bản chất cái main này cũng là một method
mà đúng không?
Ồ ok.
Hôm trước không học sâu thế này đâu. Hay
lưu lưu để thôi. Không biết mình lưu cái
này kiểu gì. Mình export này ra lưu kiểu
gì nhỉ?
Cái này copy cái này copy vào không ổn
đâu. Copy vào đây.
Copy vào bị xấu ấy.
Cái có nhược điểm nhá. Cái này tôi chúng
ta không bấm edit được.
đợi tôi một tí, tôi sẽ tạo hẳn một cái
mới.
tập trung vào học architect hệ thống hay
vẫn từ co
đi lên như ngày xưa. Anh
thực ra là cái câu của em đã phản ánh
phần nào rồi thứ nhất là em đang lo. Thứ
hai đó là kiểu em đang em chưa phải là
người nắm kiểu co mà đúng không? Nên
mình kiểu đang nghĩ là thôi mình cắm đầu
học tiếp. Hai là mình chuyển h chuyển
dần dần đúng không? Thứ hai đó là
đã là một cái nó không ổn ở trong cái
ngành công nghệ thông tin này rồi. Bởi
vì ngành công nghệ thông tin này là một
ngành nó đòi hỏi sự thích nghi, sự biến
động.
>> [hắng giọng]
>> Anh không anh nói thẳng anh hay bất kỳ
một chuyên gia nào cũng rất khó để mà
kiểu
cùng nóắm là bọn nó cứ chém gió trước
đúng không? Thường là giống như kiểu ông
Elon Mus ấ ngồi chm rõ trước các thứ thứ
nổ trước đã đấy
chứ không ai khẳng định được là tương
lai có thể nó sẽ như thế nào đấy nên
hành a nhưng mà nhấn mạnh đây đó là cái
cốt lõi của công nghệ âm tin đó là em
không ngại thay đổi, em phải thích nghi
được tốt còn không thì em dễ bị đảo thải
đấy rất đơn giản thế thôi
còn
bây giờ để trả lời câu hỏi của em cái
tập trung hơn đúng không? Thì đó là bây
giờ anh thấy là khi mà vai code nhiều
anh thấy là cái chức vụ của anh bây giờ
nó không còn là dead mấy nữa. Nó sẽ mang
thiên hướng giống như là PM đó product à
manager kiểu đấy. Nghĩa là quan tâm về
chất lượng sản phẩm và review code của
AI đã code và
ừ đại khái là review và đôi khi code lại
một vài cái giống như anh sếp của anh
hồi trước đã làm với code của anh luôn.
Đấy. Đấy nó sẽ mang thiên hướng đấy. Nó
không còn là
mình tự code từ đầu một cái. À đương
nhiên mình vẫn code tự code từ đầu mấy
cái kiểu gọi là pattern mấy cái a design
mấy cái kiểu mẫu trước để ai nó cũng
nhìn vào có một cái format nhất định thì
nó còn code theo chứ đúng không? Đấy và
mình viết đôi khi là nó sẽ kiêm thêm cả.
Ừ nó giống product manager tí nó là thôi
khi mình viết tài liệu nhiều.
Viết tài liệu để làm gì? Bởi vì chính
mình mới hiểu được cái product của mình
nó đang như thế nào để mà mình viết ra
tài liệu để mà AI nhìn vào biết được nó
sẽ làm gì tiếp theo. Ví dụ input output
là gì đúng không? Đấy chẳng hạn thế mình
lên plan các thứ như nà hoặc là hôm
trước đấy nhắc tôi tôi xin phép nhắc một
tí. Đấy, hôm trước có ông chia sẻ về
cách vi code này này. Đây đề cập đoạn
này luôn này. Đó là sẽ bảo nó phỏng vấn
mình rồi
rồi mình sẽ trả lời cho nó là từng bước
từng bước như nào để nó tự viết ra. Đây
nó viết document cho mình các thứ thứ để
nó sẽ dựa vào cái đấy. Đấy, rất là hay.
Hiện tại là AI bây giờ cũng có vài con
giống con antiity này tôi đang thích bởi
vì nó có lên khái niệm lên blending nó
sẽ lên cái cái file Md kiểu liệt kê và
nó có hỏi lại mình confirm lại mình vài
cái vài cái thôi nhá nếu mình bảo nó có
thì nó sẽ chuẩn hơn là để nó chỉ hỏi
mình mỗi vài cái. Đấy xong rồi nó sẽ lên
một file file plan này. Xong rồi file
work through này. Thôi một file file tab
chính là file checklist là nó sẽ làm
những cái gì rồi nó kiểu đánh dấu vào đã
làm ấy. Hay phết. Tôi thì thực ra là bọn
này vẫn thiếu một cái cơ không biết nó
có tính vào cái work work true không
nghĩa là khi nó làm thế rồi làm gì câu
chuyện nó làm một phát ăn ngay đúng
không ạ? Nghĩa là
mình vẫn phải bảo nó sửa lại vài cái
đúng không? Thì đôi khi nó sửa lại luôn
ở trong tài liệu cũ. Đấy tôi thấy thực
ra hơi nhược điểm. nó chuẩn là nó sẽ
phải viết thêm ở trong hôm đấy hoặc là
nó sẽ viết theo dạng là hồi trước tôi
bắt nó phải viết thêm một cái file nữa
là file chlog tức là đã thay đổi những
cái gì ví dụ giả sử là ở trên mày mắc
cái lỗi a rồi đúng không đấy bảo sửa rồi
xong rồi ở dưới nó lại mắc lại cái lỗi a
vì kiểu đôi khi là nó out contex kiểu
dạng con ai nó cũng chỉ nhớ được một cái
lượng nhất định thôi mà đúng không nó sẽ
quên mất Đấy. Đấy, nó lại mắc lại lỗi A.
Nó đã từng thử cách đấy để bị mắc cái
lỗi A nhá. Xong rồi vài đoạn đoạn dưới
dưới nó lại què. Đấy, mình phải nhắc lại
đúng không? Đấy, nếu mà nó lưu lại cái
trên log như thế nó đã biết nó đã làm
cái a à nó làm cái a rồi nó bị lỗi ra A'
rồi thì nó nó nhìn lại nó nhớ để nó
không làm lại cái A đấy lỗi tiếp đúng
không? Tứ nhiên là thế.
Đấy thì thằng anti này nó đã làm tốt
khoản là nó tạo ra quả plane plan này.
Đây tôi ghi rõ ra cho mấy ông nhá. Plan
này work true này. Work true là kiểu
dạng thôi không biết là viết đúng hay
không nhá. Ở đây và tas cái này nó sẽ
chính là to do list ấ kiểu danh sách
những cái đầu việc cần làm ấy. Đấy work
to này là nó lướt qua những cái kế hoạch
các thứ thứ. Đây kế hoạch rồi nhá. MC
thu này thì tôi quên mất nó là cụ thể là
những cái gì nữa rồi. Nhưng đại khái thì
cái nó vẫn đang thiếu một cái nữa là cái
chen lọc và đã làm những cái gì đấy.
Đúng rồi. Lịch sử thay đổi là nó làm bởi
vì mình bảo nó sửa xong nó sửa lại vào
luôn trực tiếp vào ba file này làm cho
nó quên mất là cái vừa nãy nó đã làm gì.
[khịt mũi]
tôi nghĩ là tôi đã trả lời được phần nào
cái câu của bạn vừa hỏi. Còn nếu bạn cần
hỏi thêm nữa thì đây vào đây đọc thử,
nghiên cứu thử nhá. Cái file code đây.
Nghĩa là thứ nhất là không nên sợ AI vì
AI bây giờ nó đang là một trợ thế khá là
tốt nếu mình biết tận dụng nó. Đấy, còn
để biết cách bây giờ mình phải nói là
biết cách dùng AI như nào nó na giống
như hồi trước hồi trước là tôi thường
hay dạy mấy ông đó là mấy ông đôi khi
hơn nhau ở cái trình là việc cách trao
Google thông minh hơn. Ông nào biết được
từ khóa ấy thì bây giờ thời gian đầu AI
mới ra thì nó sẽ biến thiên về việc là
ông nào biết prom chuẩn hơn ấy, ông nào
thậm chí cũng phải liên quan biết từ
khóa cơ vì AI thời đấy nó cũng chưa đủ
thông minh để mà hiểu được. Đôi khi là
đôi khi không hiểu tiếng Việt ông phải
nói tiếng Anh chẳng hạn. Còn bây giờ nó
hiểu tiếng Việt tương đối tốt rồi. Thì
lại về việc là ông phải làm sao quản lý
được cái chất lượng của nó ra. Bởi vì
prom của ông có thể nó như nhau rồi nhá.
Tôi cảm thấy là ai dần dần kiểu nó còn
hỏi lại mình các thứ thứ để xác định lại
mà nên prom của ông lúc đầu vào có thể
ít. Thậm chí là mấy cái con kingh này
này hôm trước tôi từng nói ông mấy ông
người vụ đấy mấy con kinh này nhá ông
prom càng chi tiết lại càng chết bởi vì
con thanh kinh này nó sẽ tự nghĩ hộ ông
còn nếu mà ông càng chi tiết nó sẽ càng
giới hạn về nghĩ của nó nó không nghĩ
thêm nó sẽ chỉ làm đúng cái ông nói thôi
thành ra là kiểu nó lại bị ngu đi. Chắc
gì ơi, nói thẳng luôn, chắc gì mình khôn
hơn nó ở nhiều cái mà mình bắt nó phải
làm giống hệt ý tưởng của mình. Hà mình
chỉ cần cho nó mỗi cái input và output
rồi bảo là mày tự nghĩ cái xử lý tiếp
theo gì. Và đôi khi tôi toàn phải nói
tôi toàn nói với nó không phải những cái
câu
trừ những câu ra lệnh kiểu chắc chắn ra
nhá. Tôi sẽ thường hay nói là tôi nghĩ
thế này ông xác nhận lại cho tôi được
không chẳng hạn. Thế đấy ông có kế hoạch
nào khác không? Ông nói ưu nhược nó vân
vân là gì các thứ thứ ông thể cho tôi
giải pháp khác nữa được không? Đấy nó
phải câu hỏi mở như thế để nó nghĩ thêm
cho mình đấy. Gợi ý thêm cho mình đấy.
Mình hãy coi nó như một thằng xong xăm
để mình ra lệnh chứ không ra lệnh và nó
sẽ gợi ý ngược lại mình. Tránh với việc
là
mình đã kém rồi, mình còn ra lệnh nó ép
nó theo khuôn mình nữa thì đấy là cách
dùng ai không tốt đúng không?
ông cần gì và ông bắt nó làm giống hệt
thế thì nó khác đúng không? Thế thì
không nên dừng con thên kinh. Ông dùng
hẳn cái con bình thường thôi.
lại thì sao? Đúng, cũng có thể. Tôi đang
hơi lười mà.
Tôi bảo nó thử viết lại. Ừ nhưng mà thôi
viết lại cho giống hệt cho nó được đi.
Dùng bắt nạt Jemini đi. Tôi ghét thằng
Yamini á. Tôi bắt lạt nó.
À
nhưng mà thằng này đôi khi hơi ngu về
khoản bảo nó biến lại thành cái file gì.
Đôi khi bảo tôi không làm được đâu.
Thật tí cho xem. Đây bây giờ cho xem
luôn nhá. Đây
>> hả? Thế chưa bảo là tôi không làm được
>> mấy lần anh bảo nó thế mà không làm được
đây.
Bro ở no đã từng có đứa bảo với anh là
chắc là ông dùng bản miễn phí bro là nó
mà
thấy
>> à không thằng này toàn bảo tôi không thể
làm được cái điều đấy vân vân vân kiểu
tôi không hỗ trợ tạo ra file gì thằng
thằng chat vt thông minh hơn cái đấy
nhiều nhở
à
viết lại theo dạng vào để tôi có thể
copy. Đấy,
tôi từng à nhờ thằng chatt làm này để
xem nó thử thằng này nó chỉ được khoe nó
toàn không khoe thông minh con đ chatvt
nhá. Nó toàn khoe nó contex dài hơn
chatvt
về AI.
À gần đây anh có để ý những cái thấy
không?
không? Đần mãi
Đợi tí mở mở mấy cái AI này ở
công khai đôi khi dính vào mấy câu hỏi
hơi nhạy cam. Tôi phải cứ
>> đây
nhìn nhá.
[khịt mũi]
Con nốt thích
>> không thích
bắt
viết dạng down
cơ mà. Đấy hỏi lại phát nữa nhá. Tôi nhớ
là tuy là chadity từng ngu một lần như
thế nhưng mà lúc sau nó vẫn chả được
lại.
không được thấy không?
hơn rồi
hả? Copy ra á? Ông đừng lừa tôi. Copy
này ra ma down kiểu gì đây? Ông bảo copy
cái trên này ra ma down đúng không? Cái
này ra ma down đúng không? Thầ copy nhá.
>> Xin lỗi đi. Xin số tài khoản
>> xin lỗi.
>> Xin số tài khoản đi.
>> Xin số tài khoản à? Xin số tài khoản của
ai? Của ông đấy á.
Tôi chửi thằng chatt à chửi th mini mà
>> xin tài khoản cảm ơn sá
>> ơ thế tại sao không bởi vì tôi đã từng
copy thật à hồi đấy là copy bên chat DVD
hồi đấy copy bên chat DVD là không không
được
>> đây thật mà lừa làm gì đâu xem nha
[tiếng cười]
>> bây giờ lại được rồi này bọn này lừa Và
[khịt mũi]
nó cập nhật thế nó cập nhật là không báo
anh lừa
anti varity kit có dùng rồi tôi thấy tôi
dùng được mỗi cái xịn nhất của nó là cái
workflow
à UIUX Pro Max vì tôi làm giao diện kém
xong rồi tôi từng nhờ
Gemini
3 Pro xong rồi up cái gì à upper à
output này với sonet kinh nói chung đủ
kiểu sửa cái đoạn đấy mãi không được
xong rồi thêm con antigravity kit kia
đúng không có để là uiu pro đấy à pro
max đấy xong rồi nó sửa một phát được
luôn ạ đỉnh vãi về kiểu khai sáng
trong
sẽ ơ ấn nhầm tôi sẽ là cái gì nhỉ?
Đây lưu nó sẽ là
doc.md.
Đấy.
Cộng đồng. Còn đây là build in public
này. Cái này là chuyên để mà ông chia sẻ
những cái phần mềm hay ừ phần mềm của
ông mới làm để công khai cho cộng đồng.
Thường là mấy cái liên quan đến startup
các thứ.
[hắng giọng] Anh em chia sẻ trong này
nhiều thấy mấy anh em chất các thứ. Đây
cộng động to. Tiếp theo là tôi gần đây
tôi tham gia cái antiravity
Việt Nam. Có hai cái nhá. Đừng vào nhầm
cái nhá. À còn cái gì nhỉ?
Ờ
có vừa nãy có tôi có đề cập ấy có nhiều
anh em a nhiều anh em
kiểu
tự nhiên đột nhiên xuất hiện trên trang
chủ cá nhân Facebook của tôi cho dù tôi
không ngắn theo dõi nhưng gần đây tôi
theo dõi hết rồi mấy anh a em chia sẻ về
AI nhiều
và mấy anh ấy thỉnh thoảng anh ấy có
nhắc trong cái build init này đợi tí tôi
không biết có một cái tôi nhớ là Có một
cái nhóm riêng Facebook đấy. Đợi tôi một
tí nhá. Xem lại qua Facebook bây giờ nó
đổi sang giao diện đần vào anh vậy. Nút
setting ở đây đâu rồi?
thay đổi giao diện dành không hợp người
già lắm.
Hử?
Mượn điện thoại
Đấy. My ông có thể tra cái này.
chưa chắc chắn đâu đúng không? Mình sẽ
chơi chó
cho tôi dạng MD tiếp.
double check AI đi.
doc này sao cho phù hợp.
Thực ra hôm nay còn chưa học đến bài 5
nãy chưa nhắc gì đến bài 5 nhắc lại mà
đã tiếng rưỡi rồi [tiếng cười]
chưa học gì cả không sao vẫn học mà vẫn
học quá học lại bài cũ vậy
ừ đúng rồi tôi gần đây tôi chuẩn bị phải
lên công ty để mà
quyền đồ trên đấy và công ty tôi mới đổi
văn phòng nên tôi đang chuẩn bị ngồi nói
anh em mình một tí nữa thôi xong rồi
lại lên công ty tôi hôm nay ngồi chỉ
ngồi tạo doc chia sẻ tâm sự với anh em
nhá cũng chưa ngồi học được
học cũng được mà
[khịt mũi]
hôm sau học cả bài 5 bài 6 luôn được đc
chấm md
tại sao đến đoạn này dừng
Đây này. Nó đểu này. Nó chỉ đến cái đoạn
này thôi.
Viết viết trong này bị sai rồi. Cái này
có bị nhược điểm là nó đóng ở đây nên
thành ra mất.
Thử thử ở cuối xem nào.
anh stream được luôn đó
cứ ai định tôi đặc bến hồi trước có
người khen tôi đẹp dài thôi không thể
tin được luôn.
Ngọ nhỉ? Bảo tôi nhiệt tình thì tôi sẽ
tin. Con đẹp trai hay là cốt giỏi hay
cái gì đó tôi cũng không tin nó lắm.
đây nó sửa thằng này nó sửa lại cho tôi
rồi này
đ chuyện
>> ơ nãy là có anh em bình luận nhiều hơn
rồi đấy đợi tí a
có những cộng nhau tận
học bản chất sa phương ước bị ngố
về ạ AI Studio nhưng mà tôi lại chưa
dùng cái đấy cơ sếp tôi chưa từng dùng
thì
hình như video hôm trước tôi từng có đề
cập nhá
cả tài liệu này nhé.
mục tiêu của project này. Đấy,
tôi dùng thằng này vì tôi tin là thằng
này nó chuyên về
tài liệu và chuyên về giao diện. Hôm
trước có ông phân tích là như thế. Thằng
Pro thì thế.
À thằng Gemini thường về giao diện,
Cloude thì về
code. JBT thì cui bóc thự ra đùa đấy.
GVT hôm trước có ông bà GVT hợp để đi
bấc
lên kèo còn định giao lưu nữa không ạ?
Có chứ. Tôi thường xuyên lên ấy chứ
chẳng qua là anh em ít đi rồi thực ra là
tôi vẫn hay đi mà tôi gần đây ít đăng
lên đấy thôi chứ đi hàng tuần vẫn đi đi
với anh em phải ra ngoài cà phê thậm chí
có thể mãi cũng được anh thì ở Hà Nội ừ
maiãi cũng thể được để xem mai thế nào
tôi vừa đặt khám nha khoa xong
răng khôn ở 30 tuổi mới nhổ cái răng
khôn thứ hai. Chắc cũng muộn. Nhiều
người bảo nhổ hết từ năm hai mấy rồi.
nguyên mà đúng không?
Ơ vừa rồi hình như là mình gửi nhầm file
tôi gửi luôn lại file này. Sửa cả file
này nữa.
antiravity thằng Queense nó bắt đầu cập
nhật hiển thị lên là đang bao nhiêu phần
trăm contex rồi để mà tránh việc là mình
thấy 100% rồi tức là nó không nhớ được
cái lượng ở trên ấy thì mình nên tạo hẳn
cái chat mới.
Đấy thằng Gemini này thì nó cậy nó lợi
thế là nó lưu đến 1 triệu à 1 triệu
contex thôi. Nghĩa là cứ cho contex ở
đây là 1 triệu kiểu chữ cài kỹ tự ký tự
nhá. Chứ còn à không thể tính mỗi chữ
cài ký tự ở đây được vì nó đọc cả cái
khác nữa. N nó nó vẫn nghĩ. Nhưng mà
thằng anti này tôi thấy là nó vẫn đang
đi sau thằng nhiều quá.
Từ hai xếp
đó sửa lại rồi.
À
đi nhanh.
Tạo doc
MD cho ba thư mục này luôn cho tôi
đấy. Thôi hôm nay chưa ngồi học được.
Mày ngồi tạo xong rồi tôi còn phải đi.
Xin phép anh em
không sau nhá. Hôm nay ngồi ngồi học à?
Không ai ngồi như này đã làm một cái á.
Được rồi.
nó mà. Cho dù là đang 3 tháng đầu thì
giá vẫn rẻ nhưng mà mình
hôm trước còn lúc mà bị antiity sập là
tôi còn vừa mua cả Winus 1 tháng nữa.
Tính là tháng này vỡ mồm tiền à vỡ mồm
hơi quá nhưng mà đại khái thì
mất tiền cho anh nhiều mà.
có cái ảnh đẹp hơn
à đây thích tạo ảnh được mã nhìn nhá ông
mấy ông nhìn nhá
này.
đợi một tí. Bây giờ ấn download
không muốn.
[tiếng cười]
cảm quên mất.
thôi nó sẽ tự động đưu là bng. Ok. Ơ lì
con mẹ do
ông thấy tôi ngồi kiểu chuẩn trì không
được nhỉ.
Đấy ta tài liệu các thứ như này rất xịn.
Cho dù là mình không biết mình có xem
lại không nhưng mình quan trọng trông nó
xịn.
ching pu không? Cái này đề cập string p.
trong
string pool này xong tạo string các thứ.
Mấy cái ảnh này không đủ để mà diễn tả
cái đấy rồi.
rất màu mè đúng không? Tôi thấy rất màu
mẻ không biết được anh em có xem không
thì tôi sẽ xem.
Đ chbng.
Đấy, tạo thêm vài cái nữa.
Đúng, mình bóc lột ai thật
mà nó có là miễn phí. Con này miễn phí
mà.
tạo ra hình ảnh khó chịu vậy.
>> không tạo hình ảnh cho nó đẹp thôi. Mày
điệm thật đấy.
Bảo V đem tự ái
>> vẫn tự ái mắ à.
>> Anh muốn làm đẹp hẳn không? Và chỉnh sửa
được không?
>> Mình vẫn phải bấm vào chỉnh sửa được mà.
>> Vẫn chỉnh sửa được á. Ừ mình bấm hẳn kéo
xách các thứ
>> tch có thể thêm vài cái được mà mình có
thể bấm thêm được thôi
>> cái cúp vừa rồi đẹp hơn đây cái cúp này
đấy
>> cúp này
>> thế là anh nói là nó thiên Yên về tùy
cái th cúp nó cũng không phải phản ánh
được cái gì cả.
Cái bảng này có
>> đây như này này đấy
>> đấy đây đấy. Thế thì giống cái này
làm
xịn cho mấy ông
tuy à thực ra cho tôi đã.
Cái gì đấy?
À không ấn nhầm nút đã.
Ấn nhút mà.
Em xem cái bảng
Dog chb bngng trông đẹp mà đúng không?
Trông dễ hiểu đúng không? Ông thấy dễ
hiểu đúng không?
>> Ở bên này nó cũng có
>> tôi thấy dễ hiểu.
>> Ở bên này nó không có cái cái bảng xem
kìa.
vừa rồi còn hiển thị là dùng mà lúc nào
cơ còn xịn hơn? Thì cái này cũng tự lâu
rồi muốn đi học cơ.
>> Làm sao xịn bằng của anh được.
>> Kin
>> Ai tạo ra mà miễn phí rồi. Hết rồi. É
vừa nãy có ông nào bảo tôi vắt kiệt cơ.
Địt mẹ nó vất
hết trong tuần nay rồi. Thôi xem mất bao
nhiêu.
9 đô một tháng để
dùng.
Thông cảm anh em thông cảm. Bình thường
tôi sẽ không khuyên anh em chơi trò này.
Nhưng mà tôi muốn làm nhanh.
Làm còn hai cái ảnh nữa mà chắc không
anh em nào phán xét tôi đâu.
cưới
Cái gì đấy?
Pent này,
data này, brainstorm này, social đấy.
À
socioal này. Đấy, create
tài khoản mới nó có hướng dẫn như này
luôn à.
Tại sao mình hồi đấy mình không có cái
hướng dẫn này nhỉ?
>> Chậu nước
>> trông kiểu
>> anh đ nghĩ đầu
Màu mè nhỉ? Mày không thấy màu mè không?
Uầy cái gì đây? Xếp hình à em?
Ờ cái này là kiểu cái gì nhở? Ờ tiếng
Anh nó gọi là cái gì ấy
>> quên à.
>> Magic
>> không magic.
>> có chữ D
>> không cái này magic mà
>> magicame
>> brick à.
Tôi nhớ magic mà đúng không? Đây này.
Đây này. Cái từ này này. Chữ này này.
Cái chữ này là gì? Prin à?
>> Tuấn đọc thì không biết.
>> À puzzle á.
>> Puzle là giải đố nó chung chung thôi.
Ơ game này magic à? Game này tôi nhớ
magic mà đúng không?
Game này
X
cầu pháp lý này? Không có không có không
có gì.
này PP ứng dụng chết sau mỗi request ít
quan tâm memories Java ứng dụng sống
hàng tháng trời
tạm thời.
Uầy
cười với chưa?
lâu dài vòng đời object pass by value
luôn luôn copy bất biến trí dọn dẹp tự
động.
Ôi cái này dễ hiểu không này?
Được không? Mấy ông thấy ổn không? Nhưng
cái này có một cái nhược điểm nếu mấy
ông để kỹ thì nó không nhắc đến mấy
stack với hip là trong khi đó cái bài
gốc này là stack và hip chứ không phải
là cái về mỗi cái vòng đời này cho dù nó
có nhắc hip ở đây này.
Stack ở đâu nó không nhắc thấy stack ở
đây. B hiểu vì tôi không?
Nghĩa là cái này trông phải rất là hợp
lý nhưng mà nó không ứng dụng cho cái
bài này.
tôi nói thế thôi nhưng mà tôi lười rồi
không ạ.
dùng kiểu
học nhá hôm sau học tử tế nhá hôm sau có
thể ngày mai. Có thể thôi
hub bây giờ chắc là xịn lắm
xem Java
đây
mới có hai sao rồi à thôi không sao đấy
bề sau mình sẽ kiểu có doc ở đây để ảnh
ở đây để Xem. Đấy, quá xịn. Đọc ở đây
xem này. Đấy, xem kiểu như này này.
học. Quên mất. Thôi để mai làm. Bởi vì
tôi chưa học nên tôi còn không biết được
là cái nào quan trọng để mà tạo ra cái
file file
kia dễ hình dung. Để để hôm sau nhá. Tôi
tôi sẽ
đóng máy lại để mai mở cái này lên xem
được luôn.
này là file gì nhỉ? Tôi còn không biết
file này file gì.
F ấn mở cái gì thôi.
đc đấy.
Hệ thống ẩn desktop file thì phục vụ fer
hoàn toàn giá trị các thứ các thứ tự
động trong hầu hết thư mục các thứ thứ
không nên commit nên git nên cho git và
cho vào git x ok
xong
cũng dùng cái tool đơn giản ok cảm ơn
mọi người đã xem tôi xin phép tôi phải
lên ngồi
cho lên văn phòng mới một tí.
Tạm biệt anh em nhá. Có gì anh em đi ăn
đêm đi nhá. Đói đấy. [khịt mũi] Bye bye
anh em.
1 tiếng rưỡi. Ok hợp lý.